dans et bien nous allons lancer le match
et pour le lancer je retrouve un
animateur a hit parade même celui qui
nous apporte soleil il est venu de la
côte
ça va il fait beau là bas notre ami
julien lepers de radio monte carlo
bonsoir à tous c'est lui qui est
maintenant malgré les performances des
cinq chansons en compétition la première
chinoise et rimbo le pop concerto voilà
c'est sa chanson numéro un chinois he
the rainbow par le pop concerto
orchestra qui fait une très très belle
carrière au hit parade mais qui hélas en
est sorti maintenant une paralysie
grands prix suivants numéro un chinois
cnpc retour